travis scott
and stormy webster are giving back this
holiday season
check out the daddy daughter duo helping
out at the rapper's 2020 holiday toy
drive event
on tuesday thrown by travis scott's
cactus jack foundation
in partnership with the city of houston
and mayor sylvester turner the contact
list drive up event
took place at sunnyside park in houston
the same neighborhood that the 28 year
old musician grew up in
the event helped present two thousand
toys to one thousand students across
three local elementary schools and the
faculty and local residents
serving a whopping two thousand people
total
i'm excited about it and stormy's famous
mommy kylie jenner
couldn't have been more proud of her
baby girl posting this pic to her insta
story and writing
big girl supporting her daddy at his
christmas food and toy drive
i love it not only did they give out
toys to families in need
but they also handed out produce
christmas trees comforters
blankets shoes and ppe gear but stormy
isn't the only kardashian jenner kiddo
to give back this season
it's such a beautiful thing earlier this
month khloe kardashian hit up
instagram to share how she and her
little girl true
are giving back this holiday season
you look so pretty in your christmas
outfit what do you say
the mommy daughter duo stopped by their
local fire station to donate to a toy
drive
and the whole thing couldn't have been
sweeter
the 36 year old reality star captioned
the post in part
quote i know true is young but i think
it is important for her to understand
how blessed and fortunate she is
it's so important for her to see how we
give back to others
especially in such unprecedented times
and she wrapped up the whole thing in a
pretty little christmas bow
writing happy holidays from true and i
you